Hi, my name is Eduardo Axe, I'm the author of an obscure
reference package called EV, and I think that it's better to start this
presentation by the middle of the story, by this world here, Maxima.
Maxima is a computer algebraic system that has several interfaces.
One of them is WX Maxima that looks very modern and it's very pretty,
and it looks like this. It's a cell-based interface. We can
type an expression here and execute it.
Here's the result. But I don't like that interface because my memory is
very bad. I typed very slowly and with lots of mistakes.
So for me, this ignorant interface that I'm going to show now
is much better, and here I'm going to show how I am teaching that
ugly interface to beginners. If I type F/8 on these three lines here,
it creates a Maxima running inside the Max, I mean,
using a terminal and running inside the shell buffer in Max,
and if I type F/8 on these lines here, the F/8 sand lines to Maxima,
and that is a small problem through this. I live in Brazil when people
in developed countries cannot imagine how are the
beginners that we have here. In the sense that Brazil is another planet,
let me explain why, and also let me explain why Maxima,
why Max? Because people always say you should use
programs that everyone finds intuitive, like VS Code.
Well, I teach calculus in a bad campus of a good federal university in Brazil.
My university is called UF for Universidad Federal Feminés.
The main campus of UF is in Italy. It's that's a big city in here,
here, here, and here. And I work in a city called Here's Azurstras,
that is a small city, 200 kilometers away from here, here, and here.
I started working there in 2009. My campus gets
very little funding. That's a long story that I don't have
time to tell now, and we get the students that don't get enough marks in the
admission process to get to better places.
Also, my campus has two institutes. I call them the Institute of Humanities
and the Institute of Inhumanities. Each of our institutes has a small building.
The Humanities Building has lots of plants and lots of graffiti.
I call it the Good Building. And the Inhumanities Building has lots of rules
and prohibitions. I call it the Evil Building.
I heard that the Inhumanities Building has a laboratory with computers,
and that it doesn't have any machine that runs Linux.
But the Inhumanities Building is shrouded in mystery,
and basically humans avoid it, only in humans go there.
We've only discovered how much another planet, Brazil, is a few months ago.
In May and June of this year, the Federal Universities in Brazil
paralyzed their activities in the nationwide strife of two months.
And during the strike, the Humanities students occupied the Humanities Building
and organized lots of activities there. They asked me if I could give some
workshops, and I offered two hands-on workshops on free software for beginners.
Basically, on MX and EV, with tutorials, with lots of try-its.
And as usual, the students of computer science and engineering ignored
the workshop completely and didn't come. But some students of psychology
and of production cultural, which is basically techniques for producing
cultural activities, came to my workshop, and they loved the workshop.
They found it fun. And after the workshop, I told the students that
there are lots of things that, between quotes, everyone knows,
and I don't. And I would like to learn them. But I find them too hard to learn
by myself because I'm a dinosaur. I'm only used to interfaces that are very
old and that they're not graphical. And one of the examples of the things that I
would like to learn is cover. And then the student of production
could route taught me cover in 10 minutes, and that changed my life.
So the student of production could route taught me cover in 10 minutes, and that
changed my life. Anyway, again, I'm working in that place, Hill Desertors,
since 2009. And the computer science students here know lots of
programs and language that I would like to learn. But in all these 15
years, the computer science students only help with twice.
It turns out that our inhumanities students don't have a culture of sharing
and helping. But our humanities students do.
Another detail about how much Brazil is another planet.
Well, I only discovered this very recently too. My research is in logic.
I sometimes go to conferences, usually in Brazil very, very outside.
And people here don't bring their laptops to the conferences.
We don't have a culture of sitting together with friends or colleagues to learn
with them how to use the programs that they use.
For example, many of my friends,
are musicians who have to draw lots of diagrams.
And I don't know how they use their problems to draw diagrams.
I don't know how things are in universities with good computer labs.
But anyway, consider these sentences that sort of everybody says.
Everyone knows VS Code, everyone knows Jupyter notebooks,
everyone draws diagrams with Quiver.
Here, these things are not true. They're not relevant.
Here, knowledge about programs do not propagate.
And one of my goals in life is to become friends with some people who know how to use,
for example, code blocks in org and JavaScript, and learn some of their workflows.
Or rather, one of my goals is to become someone who deserves help.
More on maximum for students.
Remember, our inhumanities students don't have a culture of sharing and helping,
but our inhumanities students do.
I've interviewed my students, I teach calculus two and three here.
They will learn, they will learn much faster if they learn Maxima,
and that people who learn Maxima can take an optional test and an extra max in the course.
But if they behave as typical inhumanities students,
I mean not asking questions and not helping their colleagues,
then I won't help them.
Actually, it's even worse.
I've told my students that my documentation is not good enough yet,
and every question helps me a lot.
So please ask questions and I've begged on my knees.
And now I can treat students who don't ask questions as people who won't help someone that they know
who is begging on his knees.
Now let me explain another word of the title of this presentation.
The title of this presentation is MX-EV and Maxima now.
The now in the title means in less than one hour,
and even for people who have never seen a terminal in their lives.
Well, my title is a slight exaggeration.
It only took less than one hour for one person who is a school kid from a small city in the
north of Brazil, who didn't know anything about programming, but who was competing in the local
math Olympiad, so not a typical person.
Now let me tell a story based on real events and based on a real student.
The student said, "I have Linux on my laptop.
Can you help me to do Blah1?"
I answered, "Sure, do Blah2 and Blah3."
This was all by chat. I don't remember if by WhatsApp or by Telegram.
Then one week passes and the student talks to me again and the student says, "It doesn't work."
And I answered, "What happens when you do Blah4 and Blah5?"
Another week passes.
Then the student reappears and he says, "It doesn't work."
And I answered, "Type Blah6 and Blah7 in the terminal plus press Enter."
Take a photo of your screen.
Remember, not a screenshot, it's photo of your screen.
And send it to me.
Then the student disappears again, another week passes and the student reappears and says,
"How do I open a terminal?"
Well, then, Blonk.
According to the jargon file, Blonk is the sound of that a newbie makes
as he follows to the bottom of a kill file.
I prefer the simple definition here.
From it Blonk is the sound that the person makes when he, she, or they hits the bottom of my list of priorities.
I've been using this slogan with my students.
It sounds much better in Portuguese, sorry.
I am not a telepath and for me it is 100 times harder to discover the doubts of people who don't
talk to me than to discover the doubts of people who do talk to me.
There's an interesting thing here in this presentation by Abilson and Susman.
Let me explain now this word of my title, MX.
And the idea is that learning MX can mean many things.
Learning Lisp can mean many things and in this presentation,
oh no, one second.
Sorry, back.
In this presentation they say,
anyone can learn Lisp in one day except that if they already know for Trump,
then it would take three days.
And I would add, and if the person is starting with Doom MX,
then it would take five years, why?
Because the person is using a different notion of MX,
and if a different notion of Lisp, the person is starting by spending five years learning how to
configure MX, and the person is using Lisp as a very weird configuration language.
Usually the people who start by doing MX, they start by configuring MX,
and only then they learn things like the fun, etc.
And another slogan that I use a lot with my students is that there are many cases
in which learning just the thing B takes 200 hours,
but the buttering in B, A, and then B takes just 20 hours.
Here are some kinds of beginners that I do not want to help.
First example, a person who says, "I can't read that page, it has too many links."
Second example, a person who says, "I don't want to read anything, and I don't want to learn anything.
I want something that just works."
And third example, "I don't want to look at examples.
You need to summarize everything to me in one paragraph."
There are more explanations on these kinds of beginners,
and my page about this presentation here.
And here is one kind of beginner that I really want to help.
Beginners that are nerdicates who I use to read the materials that are too advanced for them,
understanding only a few percent of what they read,
remembering just a tiny fraction of what they read,
going back to these materials later, and taking notes about what they read.
And who are also always interested in experimenting with new ways of taking notes,
transcribing summarizing and saving links to primary sources.
I'd like to say something about how I've been plonking the paragraph people,
who are the people who say, "I don't want to look at examples.
You need to summarize everything to me in one paragraph."
Well, I'm a mathematician. I work with lots of things that can only be summarized in a paragraph.
If we choose the level of who we're talking to, so we have many different one paragraph summaries,
one for each level. And in many cases, this sentence, you need to summarize it in one paragraph.
It's wrong. The person means, "I want to learn a lot in 10 minutes."
And this needs diagrams, animations, and examples.
This is an example of something in mathematics and category theory
that I only understood after too many times, after Zillions of years. It's called the Yoneda Lemma.
This is the general case, just a small thing here.
But I only understood it after understanding many particular cases,
and then organizing them in a way in which different figures have different shapes and whatever.
And the text or explanations for the Yoneda Lemma, the one paragraph explanations or the many
paragraph explanations never helped much. And they contained formulas in mathematics, but written
linearly that had too many symbols. And my mental buffer is very small. And I had to find several
tricks to reduce the cognitive overload of all these ideas. For example, I had to name the
symbols conceptually, like A, B, C. So there's a kind of a temporal order in the symbols in which
the symbols that appear first have initial letters. I had to find a way to put an unarchitectible case
in the general case side to side. They have the same shape. I had to find good conventions for
fonts and types. I had to choose good meanings for what it means for what are vertical arrows,
what are horizontal arrows, and so on. What is above without an arrow?
So how much detail should we include in our technical explanations?
Well, there are many measures for cognitive overload or cognitive overload.
For example, I asked many technical questions on the maximum mailing list that got answers
that included snippets and names of list functions, common list, because maximum is written and common
list. And I liked that. And I asked some technical questions on the org mailing list and on the hyperbole mailing
list. And usually I got answers that avoid the technical details, not that I chose the term avoid it
to denote frustration. By the way, if one of my students panics on this part here, after
setting the user and password, you will get a unique prompt. If the student panics on this and
does not know what to ask and just gives up, then plonk.
So I was talking a lot about plonking people. And what's left after plonking many people? Well,
several kinds of beginners that I want to interact with. Note that kinds is plural.
Also, I get a definition for the term beginners. I think in books that, like technical books that
start with this book is written for the persons of the type search and search, or maybe several
definitions for the term beginners. Also, a metric that lets me choose between options A, B and C
when I'm trying to write material for my beginners. For example, here again, should I explain what
is a unique prompt? No. Why no? Well, let me use another example. This one I took from a discussion
on IRC. We were helping a certain beginner that was there and one person suggested to the beginner
to do this type meta colon and then this thing here and then enter. And I suggested this instead.
Copy this expression to your notes and then type Ctrl-E, Ctrl-X, Ctrl-E. And the
minimonic for Ctrl-E, Ctrl-X, Ctrl-E is Ctrl-XF, because it is executing.
Well, for me, the option one, this option here, is very costly because the person has to type a lot
without errors and then after running that and reading this page here, the way of going back to that
page is gone. So the person has to commit lots of information to memory, either the person learns
from this page, everything that she needs, or the person learns and memorizes how to go there
the next time. And for me, the option shoe, this one, but this in your notes and then executed with
Ctrl-XF is much better because the person commits information to notes and the person learns a way
to return to this note of the manual later. And with this, the person learns another way to use her notes.
I have a lot of material about that. See, for example, this page here, there's a link to it in my
page for this talk. Also, I live in a place in which people who fight my instructions to
complex or to boring disappear, either for months or forever. So if I put an instruction or if I
give an instruction that the person cannot understand and the person gives up, I lose the person.
Now, let me do some things in a weird order. In a normal presentation, this would be the conclusion,
and it would be presented at the end, but I will present it now before the technical details.
So I was teaching a Max-AV and Maxima for students. Did it work? Well, sort of, but in a weird way.
Many students decided to take my test on a Max-AV and Maxima. Let me consider only the 35
students in the true last semester that were able to do what I asked. That was to use a link like
this one and to go to my notes. They had to go to a specific small program in Maxima,
copy that program to their notes, modify it a bit to make it solve a slightly different program,
problem, and then save the new program. So it was most a test on the interface and to test if
they knew some very basic things on Maxima. But of these 35 students, only 10 students
asked questions on the telegram group. Mostly they discussed with other students, sometimes live.
They would bring their laptops to the university to discuss. They only do that very rarely, but they
brought it sometimes. Other times they would discuss with their colleagues on the squad,
but I got very little feedback from our usability test.
So my experiment failed in the sense that I didn't get the feedback that I expected. I only got
a fraction of the feedback that I expected, but along lots of things. Well, I got very angry,
very frustrated, but I saw that I can't invest a lot of energy on students who, how they say,
once talked to me. Then they decided to make contact with some schools, secondary schools,
and to make a long story short. In one of the schools, I was very well received.
The students asked lots of questions and in the middle of the discussion, we were discussion.
This little program here that splits the frame in show windows, and displays the file help
in the window at the right. And I showed them my list tutorial that starts with this in here.
And in writing it's section, it explains code.
So I had to explain them how we can use code to pass to avoid evaluating a program.
And we can use code to pass on evaluated programs as arguments and quote, "blue their minds".
And I was amazed by the questions and I saw more clearly that the compass in which I work as a whole,
and I need to do more things outside. Now let's see some technical details.
What exactly am I teaching to these students? Basically, my old tutorial for EV was this one.
It started with a section on installing EV and then it explains
least how to use a list of hyperlinks and then lots of other things. But I'm using this new
tutorial here that I am not announcing in many places because I wanted to test it a lot before
making it very public. And it starts with other installation instructions that start with instructions
for installing WSL on a machine with windows and then installing Debian there. And then after that
people have to install a max and then they have to install a EV. And I'm also using this map
here that I'm reorganizing. So it's going to change a lot in the next days. It has true dimensional
map here and it has lots of things that I'm putting in a single place to make it easier to answer
questions and to show to the students that I have answered most common questions, most of the common
questions. Remember, my target audience is mostly composed of beginners who have never seen a terminal
in their lives and that get bored very quickly. And when they get bored, they disappear.
What are my main goals for the first day? I want to install everything where everything means
WSL on their windows machines. Then Debian, MX, EV, lots of Debian packages that they install
with this blog here. After that they need to run some example programs and some test blogs
and configure MX and create a first set of executable notes. And consider that after that the
person is autonomous. I said that the students learn how to run some maxima programs. That may be
more precise about that. The first step is something that I call the first five minute workshop
and it happens in the classroom on my laptop. And I make the students run these. Actually in the first
moment I run this thing here and then I ask them to run it themselves. So I type F8 on these
three things here. We get a target buffer running maxima. Then I type F8 several other times here.
When I type F8 here it opens a no plot window that I have to close by typing Q here again.
And that's it. And then I say now it's your turn. And the students go there. They type F8 three times
and then they type F8, F8, F8, F8, F8, F8, Q, F8, Q.
The second step is similar. It's another individual workshop also just a few minutes long
in which they happen. They learn how to access my notes. My notes on maxima are here. I mean this is
the HTMLized version. It starts with the header. Then a huge index here. Then many blocks like this.
And this is a specific block that corresponds to the thing that we run in the first five minute
workshop. And in this second five minute workshop they run the instructions in this section here.
Usually I skip this thing in the first moment. Then I explain it to them.
And they run something like this that downloads a copy of my notes on maxima parts that
copy in the temporary buffer and they can run the thing here exactly in the same way as before.
And they can also, sorry, I also asked them to run my small maximum programs in other blocks.
Like this one, for example, if we run this, it calculates the solution of a question that I put
in a test one or two semesters ago. It starts by calculating several integrals and then it organizes
all the solutions in a big matrix like this. I said that at one point the students have to install
lots of Debian packages. This happens after they have installed WSL, W, Debian, then MIX and EV.
And they already know a bit about the pitch. So they are in this section of the instructions.
And they just have to type a fade here several times and watch what happens.
After that we have many options and I have this map here and I usually choose a path according
to the interests and the questions of the student. And there are many things that can go wrong.
So this page also works as a place in which I put all my troubleshooting instructions.
And if a student have a question, I can, I mean, suppose that the student is talking to me by
what's up or the student is saying, okay, I installed the things such and such and I tried to think
blah blah and something went wrong. And they say, okay, can you send me a screenshot or a photo
of your screen? And then we can troubleshoot that by using a section of this page here.
This is a way of working progress and reorganizing this thing for the 10th time.
The rest of what can happen with these students can't be explained clearly in a video.
So I'm going to put all the other stuff in the page of the video and I'm going to stop the video here.
So thanks and bye!